I just want to make it very very clear
because I know probably if you are a
reform vote you might be hearing things
online about me that I'm a radical
leftist or whatever. Um I do this for
you. I do this for all of the
hardworking men and women in this
country and across the world who see
their living standards falling. There is
a space for you here. But there's
something else I need to say as well.
Listen, I'm from London and I grew up in
a very multicultural place with lots of
people, lots of different colors, lots
of different countries. Um,
and last weekend I had friends who were
scared to leave the house,
were scared to walk on the streets in
London. And um that's because they think
you're racist. That's what they think.
And I tell those people that you're not
all racists. Um that a lot of you are
just worried about the future of this
country
and they don't believe me.
So I need you to prove me right.
And if you see racists in your movement,
you need to do something about that. If
you guys are not able to aggressively
find your common ground and unity, that
division will tear this country apart
and will destroy the living standards
for your futures, your kids, and your
grandkids. And I'm not saying that just
to the right. I'm not saying that just
to the left. I'm saying that to
everyone. If you are divided, you will
lose. You will spend your time fighting
each other and the rich will take
everything.
You're going to need each other.